no
so I didn't know if you wanted that
accidentally when an epic cast comes
together for a movie as fiery and
action-packed as a movie like the school
for good and evil there are definitely
going to be some hilarious moments in
between takes let's get into it number
one sometimes your mouth doesn't match
your brain
we imagine memorizing lines comes
naturally
do you want the line Lawrence or no yes
please well most of the time anyway
even with all the time spent memorizing
sometimes it comes out a little bit uh
different than expected now that that
nonsense is
now that not not that
NADA obviously when digging through the
blooper reels we're going to find a lot
of instances where the cast can't get
their lines out luckily the actors are
always allowed more than one take to get
it right though we wouldn't mind seeing
an alternate cut with just one take per
scene I can't wait they say some people
can just
I can't wait they say some people can't
cheat
they say some people can't change I'm so
sorry number two king or queen does it
even matter sorry
what Sophia Wiley had a hard time
getting this jab out to Jamie flatters
it seems like nobody caught that little
mistake aside from Jamie even you become
Queen they're gonna have to find a
bigger Crown to fit on that swallowed
head of yours could it have made the
final cut if he didn't call her out
Queen who knows Queen
yeah gender neutral bro number three it
doesn't matter how many takes we do
they're going to devour it all in the
blooper reel by they we are definitely
talking about us it doesn't matter what
we do no what we are
sometimes you just gotta let it out it
doesn't matter what we
even a major professional like Charlize
Theron needs to get a few giggles and
curse words out before landing that
perfect take
do you want to go a little further back
no number four some people might forget
which character they're playing we
imagine it happens all the time I am
lady lasso dean of the school for good
luckily Charlize Theron in her lady
lesso costume was standing right behind
Kerry Washington to hopefully remind her
of the character she was actually
playing
oh God
number five sometimes it's helpful to be
affirmed by your cast mate I'm just
gonna look back a couple times at uh
listen to grego's eyes okay I'm here
baby can we say Bromance number six
sometimes that wall just comes out of
nowhere and sometimes your dramatic exit
doesn't go as planned sweet dreams never
they are definitely going to need
someone to fix that door handle before
the next take
oh
number seven not in the actual movie
only in the bloopers I present to you
today
yeah they definitely had to reset after
that one
airplane
don't the passengers on the plane know
they're filming a movie down there all
across my take
number eight in between all the stunt
work and fight choreography the cast
made time for a little bit of fun we're
definitely counting fun as practicing
your moves with your sweaty co-worker
after a full day of fight training
number nine this cast is clearly
musically inclined check out these
Stellar dance moves that we can only
assume we're done with a Pokemon Tick
Tock filter whose Tick Tock were these
posted to does anyone know let us know
in the comments for research purposes
aside from that we've also got some
excellent piano ballads done in full
makeup and costume in between takes
number 10 did you know that there was
actual Fire coming out of the ceilings
we can only imagine how many takes it
took to perform this fight Sophia Wiley
had a lot to say about the dramatic
effects implemented in the fiery scenes
I remember like during the five minutes
that the scene lasted it would get so
hot because there was like fire in the
ceiling and it was so distracting
because we're trying to do our lines but
all you hear is boom boom boom boom like
over and over and over and over again it
was really crazy but it felt like it
gave it like a very evil and dramatic
Vibe number 11. we can only imagine how
long these actors had to spend in the
harness were these panicked screams more
authentic than we realize who knows this
poor stunt performer was relentlessly
thrown around like a ragdoll but at
least he was wearing a helmet luckily
stunt performers get paid for every
single take they do on set number 12 not
even the cost costumes were safe in this
film we're being dramatic but it did
leave Sophia Wiley's arms completely
scraped up oh my gosh this is what you
were wearing in that final scene though
the dress was absolutely beautiful the
fabric was definitely a bit more coarse
than your average day-to-day wear she
had to keep her composure as she held
her cast mate through this particularly
emotional scene I had full-on scrapes
all over my arms I was holding you and
these are dangerous number 13 sometimes
you just have to let it all out
number 14. it's annoying when you want
something to break and it just doesn't
we're not sure how many takes this
actually took but we had a pretty great
time watching it play out I think I'm
gonna touch everyone shouldn't it come
pre-broken or something
number 15 and then we have the opposite
problem your unique talent is of course
oh
there are a few more that involve the
same prop this definitely caused a lot
of resets
come on everybody
that thing will just not stay on there
you go oh
luckily we find out it's not a genuine
one so it doesn't really matter how many
dumbbells it takes you know it's not a
genuine well I thought I was making a
Savory but it's not as good as the real
one lesson learned number 16 sometimes
it takes a few tries
oh my gosh shall we
foreign
when trying to pull a prop from her
costume Charlize Theron found herself
getting pretty frustrated with the
limitations of her coat it definitely
took a handful of takes to complete this
little sequence it is possible
number 17
definitely not an easy skill to Master
on or offset Sophia and Caruso
definitely had her fair share of mishaps
trying to shoot her bow and arrow
luckily she was able to get a few
practice takes in before landing on the
one that made the Final Cut number 18.
there were quite a few E.T references
behind the scenes
trying not to look like eggs
he phoned home number 19. sometimes the
wrong look can make a take completely
unusable even if you're giving your best
blue steel most of the time you're
supposed to act like the camera isn't
even there tell them all the simple and
it's straight a camera
it's okay Freya you're definitely not
alone in that regard
am I supposed to look at that Mark one
more for good measure we can hone into a
powerful right into the camera
number 20. the cast seems to have a lot
of fun on set even if they aren't always
the most graceful
sorry was this the same shoe that caused
this hilarious misstep
we can only imagine how many little
trips and fumbles were caused by the
elaborate costumes in this film
so this cast had to endure Fire coming
out of the ceiling an excessive amount
of harnessing dangerous Fabrics props
that just wouldn't break and stops that
wouldn't stop breaking as well as some
really fun down time in between scenes
what was your favorite onset mishap let
us know in the comments